a public memorial service for the
murdered rapper Nipsey Hussle is
expected to draw tens of thousands of
mourners today the two-hour service will
take place at Staples Center in downtown
Los Angeles the service will be followed
by a 20-mile procession through the city
hustle was killed in a shooting on March
31st outside of his clothing store
Milegi is at Staples Center mullah good
morning good morning Nora today's
memorial service will be live streamed
online it's expected to include multiple
speakers and performances paying tribute
to the late rapper the heavy security
presence is also expected and planned
out here including metal detectors and
of course all bags will be checked the
police are taking extra precautions
after what was essentially a stampede
last week at a vigil the LAPD is
investigating a possible shooting that
may have triggered that Stampede as far
as today's event thousands of free
tickets to the memorial were scooped up
within minutes online hustle of course
was beloved in the South LA community
where he grew up he promoted black owned
businesses and spoke out against gang
violence and you know it's worth noting
that tributes like this are incredibly
rare here in LA the last time are the
only other time a memorial was held here
at the Staples Center in downtown Los
Angeles was for Michael Jackson
following his death back in 2009 Gail
never made a big difference there thank
you very much mola